wo ist dein leben
[Musik]
aber du kannst sie noch überhaupt nicht
nico hass sein bruder nico hass sein
bruder nicht es ist kompliziert aber
eigentlich in ordnung
na klar und er kennt sich aus
das ist die gelegenheit meine idee genau
deine idee ich bin nicht überzeugt
[Musik]
was ist denn los
ich habe ein großes problem ja jetzt
setzt sich erst mal hin
ich bin mit jack verabredet so das ist
nicht lustig ich habe ihn zu mir nach
hause eingeladen
ja und ich habe gesagt ich koche ich
weiß nicht wie schlecht ich koche er ist
restaurantbesitzer sicher will er mich
nach dem essen nie wieder sehen
achim so blöd ist ja nicht außerdem hast
du das erste mal warm machen
wir bereiten alles vor roulade mit
rotkraut und klößen
ihr seid 2 sätze